On the demand side, customers in the market for a
less expensive, smaller diamond are probably more sensitive to price
than more well-to-do buyers. Many less than one carat customers
would surely never buy a diamond. Diamond were not for the
social norm of presenting one when proposing. And there are
fewer customers who can afford a bigger diamond that is
one that is larger than than one carat, hence we
shouldn't expect the market for bigger diamonds to be as competitive
as the one for smaller diamonds. So it makes sense that the variants As well as
the price would increase with carat size. Now
often the distribution of any monetary variable like dollars
will be highly skewed and vary over orders
of magnitude. Now this can result from path dependence
for example the rich getting richer, or multiplicative
processes like year on year inflation, or some combination
of both. Hence it's a good idea to
look into compressing any such variable by putting
it on a log scale. For more tips on when to use the log scale and how
to transform your variables check out the link
in the instructor notes. Let's examine the distribution
of price again. In this next programming exercise
you complete the code to generate two price histograms.